le village abrite l'atelier de
décoration le plus réputé de la vallée
saint mina qu une entreprise familiale
on y vient des quatre coins du pays pour
passer commande ou pour le simple
plaisir des yeux la famille de sa mine
donne une seconde vie à ces camions qui
datent pour la plupart des années 60
lorsque le véhicule arrive il est comme
ça notre but est de le faire briller
autant que ce camion
combien ça coûte de faire ça
ça dépend de la quantité de décoration
que le propriétaire demande les prix
vont de 15 à 2500 euros
mais plus ça brille plus c'est cher
quel est l'intérêt ça donne de la valeur
aux propriétaires ça montre que les
affaires vont bien
ce matin à l'atelier on termine la
fabrication d'une couronne un travail
minutieux qui demande de l'imagination
[Musique]
les couleurs et les motifs je les trouve
dans ma tête je fais comme j'aime
[Musique]
l'important pour le propriétaire c'est
que ce soit voyant
[Musique]
la couronne est prête elle peut venir
embellir le dessus de la cabine du
chauffeur
allez on lève la couronne pèse plus
d'une centaine de kilos et toute la
famille participe à son installation
bougent un peu sur la droite relève là
encore un peu
avant on nous demandait des décorations
simple et uniquement à l'intérieur de la
cabine
mais aujourd'hui ils en veulent par tous
c'est énormément de travail
le petit va faire ce métier non non
c'est un métier trop difficile lui il va
à l'école
le propriétaire du camion vient
d'arriver la tradition veut qu'il pose
lui-même la touche finale il a investi
plus de 350 euros de décoration
l'équivalent de sept mois de salaire
j'ai mis des décorations par tour
regarde mes enceintes 1200 au pire et
mon ventilateur j'ai aussi mis un
autoradio tout neuf
la décoration c'est très important pour
les affaires ça montre aux clients que
l'entreprise va bien
regarde ça c'est très joli ça bouge
quand on roule
on est très fiers d'avoir dépensé
beaucoup d'argent pour notre camion
[Musique]
au village de dosches un camion
nouvellement décoré ne reste jamais
longtemps inaperçu et chacun y va de son
commentaire
il est pas mal mais pour moi c'est dans
le sud qui sont les plus beaux camions
mais de la musique mais des musiques et
montre nous que ça fonctionne très bien
[Musique]
dépense rien pour la décoration
c'est important d'avoir un beau camion
c'est comme lorsqu'on épouser une femme
on veut qu'elle soit belle là c'est la
même chose
qui sont les plus importants les femmes
ou les camions les femmes bien sûr ce
sont les femmes les plus importantes
alors rien de mieux pour séduire que de
prendre la pose devant son camion
[Musique]